3 que à la fois il a réussi son congrès
et il a réussi ce matin ce discours de
clôture du congrès des socialistes à la
fois en étendant dans le registre à la
fois personnelles mais aussi en traçant
d'espérer perspectives pour la
reconstruction du parti socialiste et de
la gauche dans son ensemble
moi je lui ai dit à plusieurs reprises
il va falloir qu'on prenne des risques
qu'on soit audacieux bien c'est
exactement ce qu'il a fait ce matin et
puis avec cette idée aussi que les
socialistes pour être pour être à la
fois porteur d'un nouveau projet de
transformation de la société ils doivent
tenir les deux bouts de la chaîne à la
fois la capacité de s'indigner
parce que cette société injuste
inégalitaire et que la politique
actuelle de d'emmanuel macron renforce
encore et bien il faut être en capacité
permanente d'indignation mais aussi
d'être la gauche des solutions et il n'y
a pas d'avenir possible pour la gauche
si elle tient pas les deux bouts c'est
ce qu'il a fait ce matin vous êtes un
élu local et mène une vie faisait fort
bien de parler de la reconquête des
territoires de la reconquête par les
territoires est ce que le ps n'est pas
doublé par les républicains sur ce
terrain là oui mais quand on justement
on essaie de tenir les deux bouts de la
chaîne à la fois cette capacité
d'indignation et de solutions les
socialistes la gauche quand elle est en
responsabilité
eh bien elle fait à la fois les deux
dans la société aujourd'hui donc je
crois pas que les républicains
finalement il accompagne le mouvement il
accompagne ce mouvement des
réglementations de dérégulation et
finalement la politique économique de ce
nouveau pouvoir elle combien elle
convient très bien aux républicains donc
non la gauche justement dans les
collectivités
son souci du service public son souci de
lutter contre les injustices les
discriminations elle le montre par
l'action concrète et réelle